hello guys welcome to Friday re my name
is grace Helbig if you didn't know now
you do know and if you also didn't know
friary is a look back at my week in a
vlog diary form so let's look back on
some of the things that have happened to
me this week
good morning Friday it is Monday and
it's a really pretty day in Los Angeles
I am headed to the dentist again yeah
they gave me a crown on the back one of
my cavities and it's real sensitive and
I can't chew food on that side so I'm
gonna get that checked out I think that
she's gonna clean my teeth which is
exciting I forgot to film this but don't
worry guys the desk pointment went great
oh hello fry Terry it's still Monday
it's my night this is happening excuse
me hopefully you will see this video on
Thursday this is my favorite emoji and I
tried to do a makeup short for it and it
was so difficult to do I'm not some
weird robot cosplay Minnie Mouse I can't
I can't keep doing this oh yeah it is
Tuesday happy Tuesday for the hurry I
wear this shirt every day apparently in
my hair like this every day I'm slowly
becoming her left okay and slowly
becoming an actual cartoon character
life goals I've had two meetings this
morning really fun actually really great
meetings just a lot of driving to get to
meetings and I was like 25 minutes late
to my first meeting because I assume I
can get everywhere in 20 minutes and
it's not true we've had this
conversation before
again future grace editing this clip you
cannot get everywhere in 20 minutes but
now did I finally just hit puberty I'm
gonna shoot a collab video with Alexis
jeez all right now I'm driving over to
her place and I'm excited because fun
fact for those of exhibit for those of
you that do not know Alexis jeez all was
an extra in camp Takota she was one of
the campers and so she's got a really
funny youtube channel and we're gonna go
make some
together and after that I have one more
meeting and then I am going to
Hey hi I'm look who it is
Alexis geez all what's the cheese stand
for it's my middle name
Genevieve oh just shot a couple videos
and I think you're gonna be really funny
me too
so hopefully you guys like them in the
near to distant future when they hit the
inter waves yeah get excited get really
excited great content
hello guys happy Wednesday we are
currently on our way to you at midnight
reading our due at midnight and the
other contestants on that midnight are
Nikki limo which is really exciting and
the show wolf who is a late-night writer
and is someone that I did improv comedy
with like six years ago five four years
ago something that so it's all very
exciting by the time this video goes up
you will probably know the outcome of
the show but let's go do it
okay hi fry diary happy Thursday
it is Thursday and I only vlog in my car
Bentley today's been a busy day I've had
a few meetings all day today and I have
lost my mind my mind is gone it has
disintegrated because that can happen
science doesn't tell you those things
I'm on to my last meeting of the day
today and then in doing a show tonight a
mile turn left that was just rude but
very helpful so I cannot
I'm actually doing a show tonight at the
nerdmelt showroom the theater owned by
Chris Hardwick it's a show called risk
with Kevin Allison who was my very first
ever sketch comedy writing instructor
teacher at the people's Improv Theater
back in like 2006 and he's been - thank
you 800 feet and he's been doing this
show in New York and brought it to Los
Angeles and it's a really fun
storytelling show slash podcast every
month there's a theme every month they
have a theme and then they bring a bunch
of storytellers in or people to tell
stories based on the theme this month's
theme is eek feels very appropriate my
god all right way out we're gonna go do
that after this last meeting that's it
cool
chats great time oh my god I forgot to
film the show but don't worry guys the
show went great
hi friary happy actual Friday it is
Friday
this morning I got my hair did did did
by Wendy JD's love routes are clean I
feel like a brand new robot right now I
am headed to rhettandlink studio to
shoot an episode of good mythical
morning with them and I'm very excited
because I have never done that before
I love good mythical morning and so I'm
and I love their new studio so if math
serves me correctly I should love this
experience that's about to happen
and this happens on Friday night I'm
calling netflix and chill' know hi-fi
diary
it is indeed Friday yeah cat turn onto
her side she was on her other side and
then she turned overturned I just went
for a run because I felt stressed out
and that distress is me so that's why
I'm sweaty and gross but today one when
DJ Diaz did my hair yeah then she also
got a gift for goose my dog that was
just laying on the couch she got her a
Halloween costume
look at this Frida Kahlo oh my god it's
a little dress and she made her a flower
crown to wear made her goose wasn't so
tired I would put it on her but with
Halloween and costumes be on everyone's
brain here's a quick way to look like
the Living Dead I while I was running
got a really stupid genius idea for a
last minute Halloween costume if you are
maybe a dog owner or a doll owner and
really don't have any other prospects
going for you here's this last-minute
Halloween costume what's this this is
maybe like the worst angle to do this
but it's happening so the first thing
you need is some sort of long piece of
cardboard or maybe um like a hockey
stick or a piece of wood or like a
couple paper towel rolls all taped
together just something long that you
can tape other things to this was in my
garbage next ideally you would need six
Barbie dolls if you had them but if you
don't have them that's fine you just
need like six like dolls or I'm using
some dog toys just six together
basket up twice three four five six and
then you need some sort of tape to
secure them all across the board but you
want to leave a decent amount of space
right in the middle so three on each
side I'm using duct tape ideally you
would want them all in some sort of
black or dark clothing attire but
sometimes you just have to work with
what you have and really hope that most
of the people at your Halloween party
are color blind okay
now to fasten it to yourself they're
really much better ways to do this but
this is what I can think of take a
backpack if you have it and then you're
going to slide this blank part of it
inside the backpack so that all the
dolls face the straps of your backpack
and then you're going to tape the
backpack close and then just slide the
backpack on oh no excuse me and then
ideally you would be wearing dark
clothes and maybe like a dark wig but
there you go there you have your costume
let me put it into full effect so you
understand what it is
matter they wrote wearing dark clothes
and I action looks like a clean version
of Taylor Swift easy last-minute
Halloween costume you guys so and today
look what came in the mail Duc da da da
nerdy nummies Rosanna pansino snoo
cookbook it came with a really sweet
note and this spatula super cute
cookbook that you guys should really
check out if you haven't already and
also one of my favorite videos is the
drunk kitchen that she did with this
human being Hannah Hart if you haven't
seen that you have not lived your best
life so highly recommend other than that
what is happening um maimry hart and I
are doing a show at streamcon next week
in New York City
October 30th if you are in and around
the city you should definitely come
there's information down below here's a
sneak peek yeah wow I know leave a
comment down below what your being for
Halloween and then don't forget to like
this video because that makes me happy
feelings so you can do whatever you want
honestly what makes me happy is when you
are happy and you're probably happy
doing whatever you want so do whatever
you want within reason without harming
anyone else I don't know